el apoyo que recibió la candidata de
tron quien venció a la congresista liz
cheney por la denominación republicana
demuestra que el exmandatario todavía
ejerce un gran control en el partido
republicano
la noche es andrés así es el que haya
ganado
la complican te de el eastern y una
persona con mucho reconocimiento
para su padre era vicepresidente y tiene
una larga participación en el partido
republicano entonces es algo que no se
hubiera imaginado la gente en un estado
tan rojo como está republicano como
wyoming sin embargo esto demuestra que
en efecto pronto y tener mucho control
del partido y que la gente y las
mentiras que la ha propagado sobre el
fraude electoral siguen siendo muy
populares con la base ahora no más
porque la pregunta también que vamos a
hacernos es qué está pasando con el
partido republicano en cuanto a números
uno pensaría que a nivel nacional sigue
siendo
mitad y mitad del colegio electoral los
republicanos contra los demócratas sin
embargo hay indicios que a nivel
nacional cada vez tenemos gente que era
republicana que ya no lo es
independientes que podían votar
republicano que tal vez ya no lo hagan y
también pudiera ser que estemos viendo
en las siguientes elecciones intermedias
un mayor número de gente que se
identifica como demócrata
bien ahora jane y considera aspirar a la
presidencia que tanto respaldo podría
tener no sólo del partido republicano
sino de los votantes republicanos
poco desafortunadamente si no tuvo mucho
apoyo en su estado natal y representa en
wyoming sería difícil consiguiera un
gran número de votos dentro ese partido
o incluso fuera del partido sin embargo
se ha vuelto una voz moral dentro de los
republicanos que son los never never
trump first la gente que no está de
acuerdo control y la gente que es que
niega que hubo un fraude electoral
entonces y es representativa de un
importante bloque de republicanos que
sigue existiendo que no están de acuerdo
con lo que está pasando y que a
diferencia de la mayoría están
dispuestos a decirlo abiertamente es
donde ella se diferencia que ha sido
bastante buscada esto y ha decidido
poner los intereses del país sobre los
intereses del partido aunque le haya
costado la elección sin embargo también
recordemos que ella seguirá en el pueblo
el congreso hasta fin de año y seguirá
la comisión del 6 de perdón del 1 de
enero del 6 de enero y será muy
importante y no tiene nada que perder
entonces yo creo que va a seguir
mostrando
evidencia de por qué esto fue un atento
de auto volver y hablamos ahorita
mencionado a usted las elecciones de
medio término con este escenario que
podemos esperar en estos comicios será
suficiente el apoyo de trump para que
los republicanos vuelvan a controlar el
senado y la cámara
esa es la pregunta
importante porque para las primarias que
es donde la gente más partidista
participa vota y el los candidatos que
son más de extrema ya sea de izquierda o
de derecha
respectivamente son los que ganan estas
elecciones primarias no me acaba de
perder se me en las elecciones
intermedias donde se compiten
republicanos contra demócratas y contra
algo independiente
es donde veremos que no va a ser
suficiente para todos que tener el apoyo
de trump estamos por ejemplo viviendo en
pensilvania que es que apoya trump va a
tener una gran dificultad en ganar ese
estado y probablemente se lo lleven los
demócratas y así pasa en muchos otros
lados entonces que estaban celosa
historia muy diferente a estas de las
elecciones internas dentro de los
partidos